and we begin with a major blow to the
organized labor movement
in the u.s amazon warehouse workers in
the state of alabama have voted against
forming
a union it would have been the first
amazon union
in the u.s but on friday the e-commerce
titan won a resounding victory against
the unionization drive
workers cast 1 798 votes against a union
while ballots favoring one came in at
738
although the vote involved a single
amazon facility in one state
the effort drew much attention and high
profile political support
as it was seen as a bellwether for the
future of labor activisms
especially in big companies
our correspondent jens corte joins us
now
jens why did this unionization effort
fail despite
all the attention it got
well actually amazon was writing a
pretty aggressive
campaign they were for instance
mandatory meetings where those
laborers had to um show up and amazon
tried to convince them at those meetings
why it would be not a good idea
to get a unionized and just to give you
an idea what happened with amazon
in the past pandemic a year they
actually hired
just in the us alone around 400 000
workers that was that they almost
doubled the workforce in the united
states and the laborers actually a lot
of them they complain about
the work conditions um at amazon there
was a lot of
pressure um not many uh breaks
and so also for many of those workers
that
they just didn't have the time to really
get informed outside of amazon so that
also
might have played a role uh why uh most
of the workers actually
voted with no but amazon has seen some
terrible press because of poor working
conditions
but what does this failed union effort
mean then for
fair labor in the united states
yeah well clearly i mean it is a setback
for the labor movement
the vote in alabama there's no doubt
about it but overall what we're seeing
here in the united states i would even
call it a new
labor movement and on many sides of
the aisle you see that with white color
jobs at google for example
millennials younger people they are
starting to get
organized but also if you look at
service workers delivery guys in new
york for example they're
also starting labor movements and they
are getting
organized so i haven't seen those
movements
um since i came to new york and that is
a good
20 years ago and then also at amazon we
could see
workers getting organized at other
places we shouldn't forget
this one logistics center in alabama is
less than one percent of the workforce
of
amazon so even if it's a setback and the
labor movement
is getting stronger and stronger here in
the united states
it's certainly not over yet thank you
for all your reporting this weekend
corta there in new york for us
and staying with labor the american
employment market is bouncing back
strongly
employers hired nearly a million people
in march
but federal reserve chair jerome powell
has warned for months that many jobs
lost the pandemic aren't going to come
back
in the new york borough of queens
thousands of residents now depend on
food banks
among them are people who previously
donated to such causes
and now after losing their jobs rely on
charity themselves
many of us have been left without jobs
and unable to pay the rent or bills
and so we're barely surviving
in the line laid off cleaners chefs
and mechanics since the pandemic the u.s
economy has shed 8.4 million jobs
u.s federal reserve chief jerome powell
warns
many of them may never return we're not
going back to the same economy this will
be a different economy
and one of the things we hear from from
companies is that they've spent a lot of
time since the pandemic
arrived looking at ways to have more
effective technology and perhaps fewer
people
so you're going to see some of that in
these public-facing jobs so
there will be millions of people who
have a hard time finding their way back
into the
workforce and recovering the lives that
they had just a year ago
according to the u s central bank 40
percent of americans don't have enough
money to pay a 400
bill in an emergency and even before the
pandemic some 37 million americans
couldn't afford to buy enough food for
the country's poor
covert 19 has dealt an especially heavy
blow